et bien bonsoir mesdames mesdemoiselles
demoiselle messieurs je suis vraiment
très heureux ce soir
oui comment qui êtes vous moi ce qui est
mon stick espagnol à un moment on ne
partait pareil ou mais vous êtes très
joli vent de rien mais non mais non
et dites-moi est-ce que je peux vous
poser une question organisez vous êtes
un garçon et une fille - vous êtes
quelque chose non moustic très maignan
aller chanter quelque chose en reste
encore bon pardon
c'est très bien alors à bientôt
merci mille fois j'aurai besoin
maintenant de quelques personnes pour
m'aider et j'aimerais aller j'aimerais
beaucoup avoir michel drucker et enrico
macias nous adorons la prévu